it is a place of color deeply rooted
culture and home to a group that still
follows a unique traditional lifestyle
ah la loi Takashi
or the place of zebras is one of many
Masai villages in Kenya and it is here
that one of the best-known symbols of
African traditions is created
handcrafted intricate beadwork is as
much a part of Maasai culture as heading
cattle its beauty my size love to be
beautiful and this is why we make these
beads we also love culture and as you
know we say one who leaves their culture
is a slave I'm told beading is done only
by women in Maasai culture and has been
practiced since before colonial rule the
skill is passed down from generation to
generation
today the youngest here is just three
while the oldest is in her 80s no I
can't imagine a life without beads I
just can't to unlock the meaning behind
the beads is to understand the unspoken
language of Maasai people various pieces
are designed exclusively for certain
ceremonies this one for example is only
for weddings the colors are also
assigned meaning in different villages
red for example is for strength green is
for the reach earth that feeds their
animals and orange for warmth and
hospitality but in honor loyalty Kashi
the beads serve a bigger purpose this is
our office in fact this is how we
support our families surprisingly its
young people in Kenya who are the
biggest buyers of these traditional
adornments redesigning and embellishing
the ancient patterns on well anything
the finished products end up distributed
to various shops locally and globally
but it is here at the Masai market
Kenya's biggest open-air curio shop but
yeah
people get a sample a variety of this
speed work for celebrity stylist Bryan
Babu in Nairobi Masaya jewelry has
become synonymous with his work here the
tradition and culture attached to the
beads is AG Lord as he places a piece
specifically designed for women on a man
but breaking the rules Bryan says
doesn't mean he doesn't understand the
cultural value placed on them it's a
good thing to continuously have your
heritage with you as you grow in your
art so it's something that's going to
continuously be part of me that these
traditional designs continue to have a
place in the modern world is in part
through young contemporary artists like
Bryan but even with no one else to buy
or wear them these Maasai women assure
me that they would still be designing
and handcrafting their jewelry the
practice they say is part of who they
are